So, in the first case, we will need ten bits
for each of those ten flips. But in the second
case, we don't need any bits because the result of
the flip is always going to be the same. You
don't even have to send this message. The folks at
San Francisco will already know what is the result of
those ten flips. So realize what we've discovered here, if
the output of this coin is predictable, you don't need
to communicate anything. But if the output is
random, you need the communicate the result of each
and every flip. So more information has to
be translated. If the sequence is predictable or it
has less uncertainty, then it has less information.
Shannon described this measure as entropy. He said, if
you had to predict the next symbol in a
sequence, what is the minimum number of yes or
no questions you would expect to ask. In the
first example, you have to ask a yes or
no question for every coin flip. So you have
to ask at least one question for every flip.
In the unfair coin, you don't have to ask
any questions. So the information in the second case
is zero, while the information in the first case
is one. Let's consider another example to understand this better.